[Music]
no no cool intro no fancy music i just
want to explain inflation in six minutes
i have a degree in economics i spent
years trying to understand this
so let's see if i can boil it down what
is inflation why is it rising why are
people worried and what do interest
rates have to do with the federal
reserve is raising the legislation to
raise interest rates inflation in 40
years listen i know that i make long
videos i'm into nuance i'm into
backstory well this isn't that this is
quick quick quick quick no really this
is quick let's go
wait wait wait rewind
hold on one second before we start the
timer i need to tell you that i was
going to do an ad read in the middle of
the explanation like i was going to stop
the explanation and do an ad read but i
realized i want this to be an
uninterrupted six minute explanation so
i'll even take out the youtube ads that
are on it so that it can be
uninterrupted but for now i need to
thank today's sponsor because it's
literally my job it's how i get paid
thank you betterhelp for supporting this
video and my channel generally
betterhelp is customized online therapy
that offers video phone or even live
chat sessions with your therapist so you
don't have to see anyone on camera if
you don't want to therapy is a giant
part of my life been doing it for
several years now and i believe in it
but i know that finding a therapist is
hard and cumbersome and better help is
trying to change that it's all on the
internet all you have to do is take a
quiz and they link you up with a
therapist they have a giant network of
over 20 000 licensed therapists you can
be talking to someone in like 48 hours
and if your therapist isn't a good fit
you can change for free which is a huge
deal so join the two million plus people
who are taking charge of their mental
health with better health you can even
get 10 off your first month if you go to
the link in my description
betterhelp.com johnny harris do us both
a favor and click on that link and go
see if therapy can improve your life as
much as it has mine thank you betterhelp
for supporting this video okay the ad is
over let's start the clock up again and
see if i can do this explanation in six
minutes here we go
okay first up the simplest definition
inflation is when there is more money in
the economy than stuff to spend it on
but if you're like me the simplest
definition never does it for you so
let's try this imagine a village that
has one market where people buy all of
their stuff their food their clothes but
one day the government shows up because
they're worried about the economy of
this village so they tell the people
that if they want to take out a loan
they're going to make sure that the
banks will not charge them a high
interest rate they want to encourage the
people to take out loans and spend money
oh and they also drop off a giant pile
of cash for everyone in the village and
everyone in the village is like sweet
i'm feeling pretty rich villagers now
are going to their market and they're
buying way more stuff many of them have
been eyeing the fancy electric bike in
the market that before they couldn't
justify but now they totally can because
they have all this new money the store
owner's like sweet this is great for
business but he's running out of bikes
in fact he's running out of everything
because now all of these people have
extra money and they're buying way more
than they used to the store owner is
like i can't keep up with all this
demand i should raise prices and that is
inflation but the village is all of us
and the market is the entire economy
when there's extra money floating around
and people want to spend it faster than
businesses can make stuff then all of
the businesses in all of the industries
raise their prices and that is inflation
it's a natural part of the economy it's
kind of a good thing in small doses
because it means that the economy is
growing and it's why movie tickets used
to be 25 cents and now they're like 15
and slowly over time it's fine okay
let's go back to the village and see
what happens if we keep going at this
rate the store owner has now doubled his
prices on bikes the interest rate is
super low so he takes out a loan to
build a new factory to make bikes this
is good he's growing a business but the
government money eventually runs out and
his prices are still double but now the
store owner has no one to come buy all
of his new bikes and now he has this
factory and more employees but no
customers he has to shut down the
factory lay off everyone and slowly
start lowering his prices this is called
recession
when kovid shut down the world
governments gave us money free money
they're like don't panic and hoard all
your money instead spend and borrow and
keep the economy going here in the us
they literally sent us 3 200 checks they
gave 600 bucks a week to people who were
unemployed for months and months and
months they gave subsidies to people
with kids they increased spending on
food stamps i mean trillions and
trillions of dollars of stimulus money
this was vital aid to people in need but
even people who didn't lose a job got a
check in the mail it was free money for
everyone and we spent it i just picked
up myself a new bike demand is up across
the country it's time to grind polyton
we all just got these big checks from
the government during a pandemic we're
like yolo i'm buying a boat or a peloton
or whatever pokemon cards there's
netflix fortnite a new motor peloton
a hot tub animal crossing push it out a
little bit
spending with the fact that the pandemic
also made it harder for factories and
ships and retailers to get us all this
stuff supply changes global supply chain
supply chain supplies
now you have an economy where people
have way more money than normal and
they're ready to spend it but the
economy can't get them stuff fast enough
so what do businesses do with all this
insane new demand they raise prices all
at the same time and that is inflation
i feel like we're getting this at this
point but what do interest rates have to
do with all this raising the interest
rate interest rate or the fed fed
federal reserve federal reserve most
countries have a central bank the puppet
master of the economy the bank of all
banks for that country but it's not like
a normal bank that stores our money and
then lends it out and collects interest
to make profit that's what a normal
private bank does the central bank which
we call the fed here in the us is run by
the government so their job is to set
the rules or policies that all the other
banks have to follow and the central
bank isn't motivated by profit but
rather their job is to babysit the
economy to keep it growing to make sure
people have jobs to make sure that
prices don't fluctuate too much so that
we can keep growing nicely no slowdown
no recession that is what the fed is
there for but seriously the fed is like
a puppet master and we are the puppets
and it's kind of creepy they pull
strings in the economy to get us to
spend our money in a certain way which
in turn affects how much businesses
raise or drop their prices and guess
what it totally works one of the strings
that they have to pull in the economy is
called the interest rate want to borrow
money to buy a car or a house or expand
your business you're gonna be way more
likely to do that if you only have to
pay two percent interest on that loan as
opposed to like six percent lower
interest rates equal people and
businesses want to borrow and spend
money so during the pandemic the central
bank was like we needed everyone to
spend money so they lowered the interest
rate and people borrowed and people
spent and it totally worked we're like
freaking puppets so a low interest rate
helps simulate the economy but once
again we're in this same place where
there's now too much money to borrow and
spend and not enough goods and services
to spend it on so what do businesses do
all at the same time they raise prices
to meet all this new demand all at the
same time and now your money is worth
less and that is inflation home price is
rising at their highest rate
rents are going up by nearly 24 so
that's what's happening right now all
the prices are rising kind of at the
same time what that means is that your
hundred dollar bill is now worth eight
percent less than it was last year like
the same money is worth less because
your purchasing power just got diluted
and imagine if that keeps happening like
instead of eight percent it's fifty 50
now your 100 bill is worth what 50 used
to be and that's what people start to
freak out and our economy that's built
on human psychology starts to falter and
we fall into a recession or a depression
even if it gets real bad which is
exactly what the fed is built to avoid
so they're back to pulling their strings
and they've started raising rates the
federal reserve is raising interest
rates federal reserve taking action to
try and curb rising inflation they're
gently raising the interest rate to cool
down all of this hardcore spending and
borrowing see if they can steer the ship
back on course and let's hope it works
okay did we do it did we do
did we do it in the time period that i
promised i would
we'll find out
uh
okay last thing i want to say is a thing
that didn't make it into my little
inflation explainer but a few years ago
when i worked at vox i went to venezuela
and colombia to do a borders series i
saw inflation up close and personal
because in venezuela inflation got so
out of control and they couldn't the fed
that the puppet master couldn't like
figure out how to get it back in control
that their money became worth nothing
the prices went up so high that their
money became basically worthless you
needed like a pile of cash to buy bread
so what they started doing is they
started using the currency itself to
make things like i visited this guy on
the street who was making like purses
and bags and like sculptures out of cash
because it was more worth more as a raw
material than it was as like money as a
currency which is insane that's a very
extreme version of inflation it's
happened in several countries that have
done this we're not in that situation
even close to that situation but it's an
example of just how tenuous modern
economies are they're not like pegged to
gold or whatever they're like pegged to
a bunch of humans believing that this
stuff is worth something
and it can quickly go off the rails so i
thought i'd share that little fun thing
that is more documented in the vox
borders episode that you can go watch on
the vox youtube channel so that's all
i've got um thank you all for being here
and i think you should check out if you
want to color your videos or your photos
i have lots and presets that uh you can
use to color correct your stuff i also
have a storytelling course on bright
trip where i talk about my methodology
for visual storytelling with nathaniel
drew i think that's sort of it all the
plugs i i should do at the end of these
videos but um yeah lots more to come
we're working on lots of amazing videos
and
i'm really excited to share them so i'll
see you in the next one bye everyone
okay